[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us
today for the developer
live Q&A. I'm Aja.
And a reminder that
this Q&A is live.
If you want to join
the conversation,
reach out on Twitter with
the hashtag googlecloudnext.
We've reached out asking for
your questions on social media,
and y'all have been responding.
We'll be answering your
questions during the next 20
minutes.
And first of all,
let's welcome Priyanka,
who's here to answer your
questions with me today.
Hi, Priyanka.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thanks, Aja.
That keynote was
absolutely amazing.
Yeah, so let's get
into the goodness
that Urs and Aparna shared.
A highlight for me was really
that upcoming documentary
on Kubernetes.
So cool.
I also enjoyed the Google
Cloud innovator community
announcement, securing
software supply chain,
and building sustainably.
What caught your eye?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, a lot of
the stuff you just mentioned.
Definitely our innovations
and sustainability.
The ability to see your
carbon footprint of your cloud
workloads is
really, really cool.
When I heard about it
in yesterday's keynote,
I immediately went and looked
at all my personal projects
to see the carbon cost
of what I'd been doing.
And I love having
that kind of data
to use in decision making like--
help me make the
right decisions.
But I'm mostly really excited
about the Cloud innovators
program.
I've really missed interacting
with our Google Cloud dev
community.
I want to hear and see
all the amazing things
the community has been up to.
And the innovators program
should let us do that.
And we're working on some super
special innovators-only events
in 2022 that I can't wait
to tell the community about.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow.
Yeah, that all sounds
really amazing.
I'm also excited about
that secure supply chain
announcement--
SLSA-- and how the combination
of Cloud Build and Binary
Authorization actually
helps kickstart your journey
to secure your software
artifacts by fully
automating that build process.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, that's
just so interesting.
That's so cool.
So let's get to
our first question.
We've got questions coming in
just for the folks at home.
The backstage crew is looking
for your tweets as well,
so keep them coming
in during the thing.
We'll be bringing them in live.
So our first question
is from Asher,
and it is who would
be good candidates
for the participation in
the private preview of Earth
Engine?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, so anybody
who is like doing work
on sustainable things.
So with the
sustainability lens--
if you're thinking about
financial services,
the customer packaged
goods, and their impact
on the environment,
and how all of that
can be combined together.
So yeah, anything that you're
doing with the sustainability
lens.
Obviously, it's in private
preview, so you have to qualify
and stuff.
But if you have that
angle of sustainability,
you're probably a
right fit for it.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Thank you for that.
Ah, second question came
in from Priyanka's Twitter.
I saw this one this morning as
I was coming in to do this Q&A,
and this one is
any examples-- do
we have any examples of
end-to-end Spark-based
pipelines for ML?
They'd love to see them.
Specifically, they're
interested in learning
how serverless Spark can be
leveraged in big data and ML
ops framework on Google Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, so
thank you for this question.
I think it came
from [INAUDIBLE]..
I saw it on my
Twitter this morning.
So really what it's all
about is the serverless
Spark ML framework
is about not having
to create your backend
infrastructure to run Spark.
So that's all taken
care of for you.
So you can just
run your workloads,
which is, in this
case, like you're
trying to run a machine
learning Spark job--
you can just get
started by not worrying
about the infrastructure.
So that's one part.
The other piece of it
is the Vertex Workbench,
which is the Jupyter
notebook, but hosted.
But it also gives
you the opportunity
to connect with
Dataproc, or the Spark ML
jobs that you might have
built, and run all of that.
So as a data scientist, I
can just use my workbench,
and that becomes my home
to kind of get the data,
massage it, connect with
Dataproc, Spark ML jobs.
And then get all
those predictions
right in that one spot.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Thanks, Priyanka.
That was a really
comprehensive answer.
Ah, so now we have a
question from Christopher,
and it's what are the benefits
of the innovators program?
You mind if I take this one?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, please.
AJA HAMMERLY: So the big benefit
of the innovators program
is going to be access to
innovators only events.
Like we're going to be
doing some AMAs we're
planning right now, roadmap
meetings potentially.
And there's also an
innovators virtual background
that you can download and use
in your Google Meet meetings.
Ooh, another question
came in from Twitter.
Awesome.
So let me read this one.
My POV, massive focus on
the security-- massive focus
on security focus in
the Developer Cloud.
Isn't this a topic
that matters more
for the managers of developers
than for developers?
And I'll take this one too,
if that's cool with you.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm
a manager, and yeah,
that's a really good question.
Security is vital to all
aspects of software development,
and security needs
to be everyone's job.
Yeah, managers need to
care a lot about it,
but we need to make the
tools so that developers
can do the right
thing automatically,
and that everyone
is participating
in making our cloud more secure.
And we talked about
some of those things.
We talked about our tooling
that can help you make sure
that you put your secrets
in secure locations
as opposed putting them in code.
We talked about the SLSA.
We talked about
lots of other parts.
And all of this is part of a
secure software supply chain,
but security does need
to be everyone's job.
Managers can help by
teaching their developers
and enforcing it,
but everyone needs
to take the steps to
make things more secure.
So yes, good point, but
everyone's involved.
This is a great one from
Priyanka's LinkedIn.
Is it possible to connect to
the public IP of a Cloud SQL
instance from a private
Cloud Run service?
Ooh, I've been asked this one
before when visiting customers.
Also is this
cross-project set up?
Cloud Run service and
Cloud SQL instance
are on separate GCP
projects, so can you
do a cross-project
setup with your database
and you're running a
server somewhere else?
Priyanka?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
You actually can.
So you have-- so
in this scenario,
you have a Cloud SQL
instance in one project,
and you have your
compute or whatever
is calling that Cloud SQL
instance in another project.
And you could totally
make them work
by using what is called
as private service access.
What it does is it connects
the two together even
with a private IP.
So you don't even have to expose
a public IP for your Cloud SQL
instance, which again comes
back to the security point
you were making earlier--
everybody has to
think about security.
So you're not exposing
with public IP.
You're just using the private
IP of your Cloud SQL instance,
and connecting it to
the virtual machine
or wherever you're
running your compute
to call your servers from.
So it's possible.
Private service
access is the service
you're looking for to kind
of connect the two together.
It's a VPC offering.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Priyanka.
Cool.
A question from Andy.
This is one of my favorites.
So there's a lot of ways to
run an application with Google
Cloud.
It's a huge platform.
How do I know what
I should choose?
Where do I run my stuff?
Should I run it on GKE,
Compute Engine, Cloud Run?
So many good choices.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, and this
is a question we get a lot.
And it really just
depends on your situation.
And the situations can be
a lot-- the type of team,
the size of team, and the
number of developers you have,
and the languages that
you might be using.
So there are lots of
different scenarios
in which you can decide.
So I'll give an
example of a few.
So for example, Compute Engine.
If you're migrating and you
just want to get from on-premise
infrastructure into cloud,
and you just want the speed--
you just want to get there--
I would choose Compute Engine
to just migrate as-is, and then
modernize later if needed.
Sometimes, you don't
need to modernize
if you have licensing
requirements
and stuff like that.
So that's Compute Engine.
If you want to work with
containers-- need a little bit
more abstraction--
less abstraction,
you can work with
containers with GKE.
And that gives you
a lot more control
over the number
of nodes you have,
and the processing
that you're using.
But if you might be just
wanting to run containers,
but don't want to manage the
underlying infrastructure,
like nodes and stuff like
that, and the regions,
just use Cloud Run,
because it's serverless,
but it allows you to use
your container images
and just deploy them.
Cloud Functions is kind
of like everywhere.
So you're trying to do--
handle one function, or a piece
or a feature of
code that you just
deploy in that
function as a Function
as a Code sort of service.
But it kind of
applies everywhere.
So I wouldn't say--
so Cloud Function
is not like an OR--
it's more of an AND--
like it works with any of those.
It's just more of an
extension and enhancement
of your services
with serverless.
So I hope that helped
clarify a little bit of that,
but there's a lot that
goes in that decision.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, I know.
And I really liked
how you called out
the Cloud Functions is
not an OR, it's an AND.
It's-- Cloud Functions is
just fantastic at tying pieces
together.
It's one of the things
I love about it.
And I'm just going to
point out for folks
that we have sessions on all
of these in the breakouts.
So if you want to go
learn more about these,
go look in our
breakouts, and you
can find out more about
the different offerings
that Google Cloud has.
So now we have a
question from Esther.
What languages do Cloud Run
and Cloud Functions support?
Oh, let's see if I can
do this from memory.
I've been practicing.
So GCF-- these are
the standard languages
you see on Google Cloud.
We've got Node.js, Python,
Go, Java, .NET, Ruby, and PHP.
I got them all.
Awesome.
Cloud Run supports any
language, or any library,
or any binaries that you
can put in a container.
But if you want to use the
source code deploys feature
that Abby showed earlier, that
is supported on Node, Python,
Go, Java, and .NET.
And specific versions of
those languages are supported,
so please do go to the website,
and make sure the version
that you need is the
one that we support.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Great
memory, by the way.
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh,
yeah, I've been
getting really good at
naming all those languages.
So from Selena-- ooh,
yes, great question.
When should I use GKE
Autopilot versus Cloud Run?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I'll
let you take that one.
AJA HAMMERLY: You're going
to let me take this one?
OK.
So this pretty
much boils down to,
do you want Kubernetes or not?
If you want Kubernetes, if you
want the enhanced flexibility
that Kubernetes has, or you
want to have all those knobs
and dials that you can turn
to really fine tune everything
for your networking needs or
your particular load profile,
use GKE Autopilot.
If you want to-- if
you have a container,
and you want to run it on
GCP, and that's your goal,
Cloud Run is great.
Cloud Run is fantastic at that.
And as we pointed
out, you don't even
need a container if you
use Cloud Run source
deploys for those
languages I just mentioned.
More questions.
Ooh, this one's
for you, Priyanka.
This is from Caleb.
What file formats are
supported with the Doc AI stuff
that Anya talked about?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, yeah.
So you can do images and PDFs.
So it's really about
the unstructured image
data, so PDFs and images.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Let's see what else we got.
Ooh, this one's from Mark.
Another for you, Priyanka.
Ooh, it's another
security question.
So can you tell us more
about Binary Authorization?
We covered it very
briefly in the keynote,
but it's something I've
been hearing a lot about,
and I'd love to know a
little more about it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So again, it kind of boils down
to the whole security narrative
that you mentioned--
that everybody
is kind of responsible
for the security
of the entire platform.
So in this case, the binary auth
is really deploy time security.
So you're deploying, and
making sure that your images--
or container images if you're
using GKE or Cloud Run--
works with binary auth.
So when you're at your
deployment stage, you have--
you can provide signature
authorizations on your images.
So if-- and the verification
and the authorities for those.
So if they are authorized,
only-- binary auth
will apply the authorizations.
And once the image
is authorized,
only then you can deploy it.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
So I just got the signal
that we're running out
of time, so this is
going to, unfortunately,
be the last question.
And this question
comes from Wesley.
Can I use the build
integrity features
with my on-prem software?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hmm.
Yeah, so you kind of can.
So with Cloud Build, it's
really any container image which
is built on Cloud Build,
you can use both on--
you can use it in both
on-prem or on Google Cloud.
You just have to use the binary
auth attestation Cloud Build.
And it's on the GitHub page,
so you can check that out.
But if you're building
it in Cloud Build,
you can deploy it on-prem
or in Google Cloud.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thanks, Priyanka.
Well, that was a lot of fun.
It was great to hear all the
questions from the audience.
Y'all had some great ones.
And I want to say
just a huge thank you
to Priyanka for joining
us, and answering so many
of those questions.
Be sure to join us back
over on g.co/cloudnext,
as the open infrastructure
spotlight will be kicking off
shortly, and they have
some amazing things that
they're going to show off.
Thanks for joining us, everyone.